joe biden has made another cabinet
selection it's a very important one
because it is the secretary of health
and human services
uh who will be coming in during a global
hundred year pandemic
and it turns out that joe biden has
selected someone who has long supported
medicare for all this is very
interesting it's a big deal
and it is xavier becerra who has been
chosen
to lead joe biden's department of health
and human services now back in 2017
uh when when he was also california
attorney general as he still is
becerra said he would quote absolutely
support
a medicare-for-all plan becerra will
be leaving his post as california
attorney general
he will be a huge part of fighting the
coronavirus pandemic
he will be a very welcome replacement to
the clownish trump secretary of hhs alex
azar who is just
a wild trump brown-noser now
from the standpoint of identity there is
another first
uh xavier becerra would be the first
latino to run hhs
we're expecting more more health related
announcements from joe biden very very
soon we found out about
some of them i mentioned already
secretary of hhs will be
uh xavier becerra at the cdc it will be
rachelle wilenski
the mass general hospital chief of
infectious disease here in boston
surgeon general will be dr vivek murthy
who was also barack obama's
surgeon general so these are solid
choices qualified people
now i admit what does not make sense
to me about choosing xavier becerra for
secretary of hhs
is that he does lack experience in the
area of health and medicine he's a
lawyer
now there's a counterpoint to that now
it's great that xavier becerra has
supported medicare for all
i see a lot of bernie people who like
the choice for that reason
but he does lack experience in the field
of
medicine on the other hand he has been
front and center
as a lawyer fighting for obamacare and
as
i imagine we will see as soon as joe
biden is sworn in
republicans go right back to let's get
rid of obamacare let's get rid of
obamacare even though we have no
replacement
in that sense becerra is a good choice
uh but remember that
you know biden doesn't support medicare
for all anyway
but he does want to expand the
affordable care act to include a public
option and becerra has experience
defending
the aca in uh uh legal settings
and um the the other important aspect of
this
is that the truth is that secretary of
hhs you're not really making
medical decisions you're really an
executive
managing the apparatus of health and
human services
and in that sense there's no way to
argue that becerra is unqualified now
hilariously there are some republicans
who have immediately said
uh becerra's a radical he's a radical we
can't we can't have him running hhs
and of course you know those those uh
guidelines
for what counts as radical at this point
have been completely cartoonified by the
right
this also by the way takes xavier
becerra off the list to be the
replacement for kamala harris
whose senate seat will be vacated when
she becomes a vice president
and that's another story which we'll be
covering and and
lastly there is a good chance that
becerra will have a tough confirmation
fight
in the senate i think he will be
confirmed because ultimately he's
completely qualified
but i think it has the potential to get
quite ugly
let me know what you think about this
election i'm on twitter at d pacman i'd
love to hear from you
i want to let you know that our sponsor
vincero watches is having a massive
holiday sale on all of their products
right now and you can take advantage of
it by going to davidpakman.com slash
watch a brand new high quality wrist
watch really is the perfect way
to add something fresh to your style
whether it's for you
or a gift for someone else vincero is a
brand that has a serious dedication
to the craft of watchmaking which is
really evident when you look closely at
their watches
i wear vincero watches myself lately
i've been wearing one from their icon
automatic collection it's the mesh matte
black watch and i love the sleek
minimalist design
their watches are actually sold at a
fair price their mission has always been
to make a wristwatch from high-end
materials but one that
everyday people can afford and that's
why they have over
25 000 5 star reviews
because you won't find a better made
watch for
this great of a price anywhere else you
can get
big holiday discounts on all of their
products right now
and free shipping when you go to
davidpakman.com
watch i've put the link right underneath
this video